là monsieur bonsoir je voudrais regarder
la france au fond des yeux ligne
j'aimerais beaucoup qu'ils apprennent à
tricoter à votre place je la ramène un
peu moins mais si vous ne réussissez pas
c'est qu'il vous manque qu'une seule
chose pas tout petit détail le tronc
fais les valises à paris
qu'est ce qu'il lui arrive à la baule
comme chaque semaine france info et
l'ina vous offre un voyage dans le temps
à travers les archives de la télévision
pour mieux comprendre l'actualité c'est
l'inattendu et vous êtes les bienvenus à
mes côtés camille d'auxerre et les chars
poiron journaliste à la rédaction de
l'ina bonjour bienvenue à tous les deux
alors vous camille vous avez choisi de
revenir sur ce qui rythme notre vie un
depuis près d'un an la crise sanitaire
et plus particulièrement cette
alternance entre le confinement et le
déconfinement oui et je me suis arrêté
sur un article de la charente libre qui
a trouvé l'expression adéquate dans son
édito le tic-tac infernal dur
confinement alors confiné pas confiné en
tout cas à li na
nous ça nous a fait penser à une
anarchie une petite pépite 1974 en
pleine épidémie de fièvre aphteuse une
soixantaine de communes françaises sont
mises en quarantaine et les habitants ce
pays à la règle ils se terrent chez eux
alors regardez ça se passe notamment à
plumaugat dans les côtes d'armor et
c'est une des premières traces à la
télévision française d'un confinement ce
village plumaugat dans les codes du nord
fait partie de ce qu'on appelle ici la
zone la zone ce sont 62 communes comme
celle ci mis en quarantaine
quadrillés par la troupe et les
gendarmes ceux qui sont épargnés par ce
fléau s'enferme chez eux ils craignent
qu'un parent un voisin transmettent le
virus en eux désinfectant pas la semelle
de ses chaussures ou les pneus de sa
voiture ayant pénétrer dans les terres
tous les rassemblements sont interdits
les rencontres sportives annulées
les cinémas fermés et même l'église est
touchée à plumaugat il n'y a plus de
metz plus de rencontres plus de
compétitions sportives plus de cinéma il
ya plus de 40 ans et ça fait sacrément
écho à notre quotidien
merci beaucoup camille tient après le
confinement on va prendre le large le
grand large même richard le vendée globe
se termine sur un sprint final
absolument incroyable cinq marins au
coude à coude
a priori ils ont hâte de mettre pied à
terre ça semble évident mais ça n'a pas
toujours été le cas je pense notamment
au premier tour du monde à la voile sans
escale en solitaire 1968 qu'est ce qui
s'est passé riche si je vous en parle
c'est parce qu'à l'époque on a vécu un
autre scénario mais tout aussi
incroyable il y avait un marin en tête
ils devaient gagner ils allaient arriver
et au dernier moment
il l'est
b mais tours bas il fait libye furent
que je vous en parlais le marin c'était
un personnage absolument incroyable si
bernard moitessier com qu'est-ce qui se
passe donc on est en 69 quelle histoire
après plusieurs mois passés en mer ils
passent le cap horn
ils remontent l'atlantique il va arriver
et il vise l'angleterre il va arriver
et là il envoie un message il dit qu'il
arrête il abandonne la compétition c'est
pas pour lui les honneurs l'argent la
prime c'est pas pour lui le monde des
hommes c'est pas pour lui il va qu'est
ce qu'il va faire il va donner des
explications il va sans registre et il
va donner ses bobines à des bateaux des
cargos qui passait et je vous propose de
l'écouter ça dure une minute
tendez l'oreille est tellement tellement
difficile de vous expliquer parce que
très des tricks qu'on peut pas expliquer
parce que c'est trop simple
voilà ce que je sens imaginez que vous
soyez partie dans la forêt en amazonie
par exemple épique vous tombiez sur un
temple un temple d'une ancienne
civilisation disparue un petit temps
imaginez que vous ayez compris qu'à une
centaine de kilomètres qu'à un autre
temple mais le temple principal von ah
qu'est-ce que vous faites que vous
n'allez pas entrer il faut y aller il
faut les voir il faut aller plus loin et
là pas tortiller a même si on risquait
d'entraver vous irez quand même c'est un
peu ça que je fais en ce moment je vais
aller voir plus loin parce que je sais
qu'il ya quelque chose qui loin et il
faut aller plus loin ça suffit pas il
faut aller plus loin alors vous voudriez
que je rentre maintenance mais ce serait
la dernière des folies ce serait une
connerie de rentrer en europe
je peux pas rentrer en
vraiment je peux pas il est allé voir
plus loin il a finalement il a fini par
accoster à tahiti après un tour du monde
et demi évidemment après après ce moment
là il deviendra une légende de la voile
bernard moitessier et nous on garde le
cap de l'émission ça c'était pour
l'actualité de la semaine mais que s'est
il passé le 27 janvier à travers le
temps regardez c'est le zapping de l'ina
ça s'est passé à 27 janvier bonjour
c'est ici dans sa propriété familiale du
château de clermont que louis de funès
aura vécu ces derniers jours le grand
acteur est mort hier soir vers 21h après
avoir été victime d'un accident
cardiaque après fernandel et bourvil
c'est le troisième grand nom du cinéma
comique qui vient de cet homme les
représentants des deux camps qui se
battent au vietnam se rencontrent
s'affrontent ils signent l'accord
d'armistice
[Musique]
agir aujourd'hui et demain c'est
construire une société dans laquelle
cette entreprise monstrueuse et criminel
sera simplement impensable
une centaine de courageux ont sorti le
maillot et défié le froid
anne à peine une participatif organisé à
l'initiative du collectif citoyen pour
le puma dans 50 ans sera peut-être
maillot de bain ici mais bath qui fera
trop chaud au départ ligne centrale
marie josé pérec france pour une tenue
de fitness tecau l'ordre on notera au
passage sa médaille
l'aller-retour s'extraire en 32 secondes
nouveau record du monde catégorie
mannequin après la houle du grand sud
gabart allait se faire secouer par la
foule des grands jours et ce ne sont
plus les embruns mais l'émotion qui
s'emparait de son visage d'enfant au
soir et à denain
ça ne vous a pas échappé la campagne de
vaccination contre le coronavirus est
très largement suivie par les médias les
caméras ont immortalisé le transport des
doses
les premières piqûres camille ce n'est
pas la première fois qu'une opération
sanitaire bénéficie d'une telle
couverture à la télévision annonce est
pas la première fois qu'un vaccin aura
suscité autant de médiatisation
on a tous en tête l'ultra médiatisé
maurice est la première française
vaccinée contre le coronavirus fin
décembre et bien être le ou la première
vacciner donnait déjà droit aux honneurs
de la télévision il ya plus de 60 ans
sauf que là ce n'était pas juste un
visage mais ceux de tout un village
direction bel entre en savoie on est en
1957 et c'est là qu'a débuté la campagne
de vaccination contre la poliomyélite en
france c'est la petite commune savoyarde
de belles entre quel déshonneur de la
première vaccination massive tous les
enfants et les jeunes gens soit presque
la moitié de la population du village
ont reçu une dose de vaccin mis au point
par l'institut pasteur de la réprobation
caractérisée à la différence la plus
évidente
toute une gamme d'opinion a été exprimée
défiant nous cependant des apparences ne
confondons pas courage avec insouciance
d'un autre côté disons nous bien qu'il y
aura toujours des gens fermés aux
progrès des gens donc fermé au progrès
donc déjà en 57 on voit le débat entre
les pro et les anti vaccins existent et
le journaliste n'hésite pas à choisir
son camp des stars aussi se font
vacciner devant les caméras cette fois
c'est rond 1956 aux états unis elvis
presley montre l'exemple à tous ses fans
il se fait vacciner contre la polio
médiatisation payant puisque s'ensuit un
boom des vaccinations chez les jeunes
américains alors en france on a pas
évident presley mais c'est peut-être ça
la solution peut-être mais en tout cas
contre la tuberculose une grande
campagne de communication a été menée
par l'état pour que les parents vaccine
leurs enfants c'est une des premières
campagnes publiques de vaccination le
timbre le timbre honte
tuberculeux un bon moyen d'attirer
encore les caméras alors regardez en
1958 on voit ce slogan dcg notre salut
ch en 62 bcg une assurance contre la
tuberculose en 66 le bcg le protégera et
puis on le voit à l'image situé vaccine
des bonbons tu aura alors le timbre et
sans valeurs postales mais il sert à
récolter des fonds pour lutter contre la
tuberculose et au passage pour faire de
jolies images d'enfants vaccinés et
voilà ces enfants qui présentent le
timbre un nouveau né une petite fille à
l'adolescent et ses trois timbres
différents montre que le bcg doit être
appliquée et peut l'être aux différents
âges de la jeunesse et puis tu as mis en
ce moment on entend à la télévision à la
radio des spots de pub 1 pour se
protéger contre le corps n'avait russe
pour faire la promotion de l'application
tous antico vide
est ce qu'un spot de pub pour un vaccin
ça a déjà existé mais oui ça a déjà
existé ce n'est pas nouveau dans les
années 90 on recommande seulement aux
parents de faire vacciner leurs enfants
contre le fameux trio rougeole oreillons
rubéole mais ce n'est pas encore une
obligation il a donc fallu médiatisé ce
vaccin pour inciter les parents à le
faire et voilà ce qu'on pouvait voir à
la télévision
[Musique]
ban a dit qu'il faut payer au foot et
pas la place qu'il faut plus y faire
leurs rayons rue des halles pas
d'hésitation vaccination demandez
conseil à votre médecin
voilà il ya la pub et puis il ya les
héros de la pub
en tout cas ceux qui servent de modèles
notamment les hommes des femmes
politiques
il montre l'exemple et ça rassure oui
exactement alors on a évidemment tous en
tête
roselyne bachelot alors ministre de la
santé qui en 2009 se fait vacciner
devant les caméras sous les flashs
contre la grippe a pour justement
montrer l'exemple mais cette année là
d'autres membres du gouvernement ont
décidé de faire tomber la chemise à nice
ambiance bon enfant pour de nouvelles
démonstrations d'injection après le
préfet le président du conseil général
le maire ministre met en oeuvre
humour et persuasion à l'occasion
d'éventuels risques du vaccin
de deux choses l'une soit on se dit on
verra bien où on est christian estrosi
dans quelques semaines ou dans quelques
mois de cela mais l'épidémie sera passé
entre temps son se dit franchement tel
qu'on le connaît celi est allé c'est
qu'on peut y aller et bien moi je dis à
chaque cas allez-y c'est un geste
important pour vous pour votre famille
alors cette année pas de si je le fais
vous pouvez le faire aussi puisque aucun
membre du gouvernement ne s'est encore
fait vacciner devant les caméras de la
question estrosi reste omniprésent pour
parler de la vaccination
alors avant les ministres un camille et
c'est plus surprenant des journalistes
ont également se sont également prêtés
au jeu de la vaccination oui là c'est
clair non plus surprenant une
vaccination en direct sur un plateau
télé en 1990 un journaliste qui se fait
injecter le vaccin contre la grippe
regardez maintenant le moment que vous
attendiez tous mes pommery je vous
assure et bien nous allons nous faire
vacciner avec emilien pour les médical
vacciner en direct contre la grippe a ne
sera pas pire que d'être reportée à
béraut je ne regarde pas un vous allez
va la garder
regardez comme les choses par conséquent
sont finies et vous êtes tlm unies'' et
c'était contre la grippe au moins pour
cet hiver
voilà alors simplement pour
recontextualiser c'est important parce
que la vaccination en direct sur un
plateau à france 3 j'avais jamais vu en
tout cas l'hiver en fête 89 90 en france
plus de 4 millions de personnes ont
attrapé la grippe
d'où une campagne massive dans les
médias pour sensibiliser au vaccin est
ce qui explique en partie qu'on ait pu
voir ça sur le plateau de france 3 et
merci à vous pour ses explications il y
à 60 ans exactement un événement majeur
elle est ce que le paysage audiovisuel
français pour la première fois une femme
apparaît nue à l'écran critique
protestation colère et réactions de la
chaîne qui crée le carré blanc une
semaine et une signalétique va informer
le public sur la nature du programme
une information qui existe encore
aujourd'hui sous une forme plus moderne
pour en parler avec nous carole
bien-aimée baisse membre du csa le csa
c'est le conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel qui régule l'audiovisuel
français alors nous allons revenir avec
vous sur la création de ce carré blanc
mais d'abord un mot sur la protection
actuelle de la jeunesse aujourd'hui face
aux images que renvoie la télévision
c'est une de vos missions et c'est une
tâche difficile
j'ai même en vous dire de plus en plus
difficile oui en effet merci de
m'accueillir pour en parler
c'est vrai que c'est devenu une tâche de
plus en plus difficile pour les parents
notamment puisque on vit dans un univers
multi écrans donc il ne s'agit pas
uniquement de s'assurer que les enfants
soient pas exposés à des images
inappropriées à la télévision mais il ya
aussi les smartphones les tablettes et
aussi les plateformes que sur internet
qui partager vidéos alors juste un mot
sur l'actualité de cette semaine avec
les images extrêmement violents de
de l'agression du jeune gorille qu'est
ce que vous vous êtes dit en voyant ces
images c'est oh la la il ya urgence
oui il ya urgence effectivement que ces
images se retrouvent diffusé multi
diffusés sur des plateformes qui sont
consultés beaucoup par les mineurs c'est
effectivement très préoccupant qu elle
ait pu se retrouver là je crois qu'il ya
une enquête qui est menée pour
comprendre comment ils ont pu arriver
sur la plateforme
mais effectivement de se dire que des
milliers de jeunes enfants
et puis être exposés parce que je pense
que vous même en tant qu'adulte vous
avez pu acheter extrêmement choqué par
ces images et je pense qu'il est
effectivement temps que notre régulation
qui s'applique sur les écrans
traditionnels puisse être transposée
aussi sur internet alors vraiment parler
avec vous de la protection du public
mais d'abord on va revenir sur l'objet
du délit
richard le carré blanc oui alors c'était
il ya 60 ans donc c'était avant internet
est l'objet du délit effectivement c'est
un téléfilm diffusé le 29 janvier 1961
c'est l'exécution donc diffusée à
l'époque sur la seule et unique chaîne y
en avait qu'une en 1961 donc l'histoire
la scène c'est quoi on est dans une
chambre une chambre d'hôtel on pense
c'est sous l'occupation allemande et
résistance et du dauphin séduit il a
dépassé le stade de la séduction mais on
va dire qu'il séduit la maîtresse
française d'un officier allemand pour
lui soutirer des informations
tu sais ce qu'il me dénie c'est un beau
mon dieu regarde radis don d'agacer
évidemment il n'est pas tout à fait neuf
il m'a dit qu'il avait piqué à une bonne
femme dans un convoi qui partait pour
chopin ça fait rien ça se voit
voilà les premières fesses à l'écran est
évidemment avalanche de courrier à
l'époque destinée à la chaîne mais
également destinée au magazine de
programmes télévisuels de programmes
télévisés et notamment à télérama où il
ya eu télé 7 jours donc des courriers
des colonnes et des colonnes du courrier
des lecteurs des lettres d'amis nation
on crie au scandale
il faut savoir quelque chose c'est que
le film avait été diffusé un dimanche
soir donc c'était 20h30 21h il devait
pas y avoir les enfants de voir la
télévision
sauf qu'il y avait grève du corps
enseignant le lendemain donc il y avait
beaucoup d'enfants devant leur écran et
ça c'était pas prévu
les programmateurs tv n'étaient pas
préparés car bien aimé baisse comment
est ce qu'on explique cette réaction
c'est parce que la télé est à cette
époque définitivement entrer dans le
quotidien des français
oui elle est entrée dans le quotidien
des français elle est dans leur salon où
elle trône sentiments il faut bien se
souvenir que la télévision avait une
place importante dans le salon des
français et qu'on la regarder en famille
cette télévision donc on imagine didier
20h30
après un week end on se retrouve en
famille je vends le petit écran je sorte
de se retrouver face à des images ce
scénario assez improbable en plus donc
je comprends l'avalanche de courriels
même si plus pas facho pense que les
français c'est pas par rapport au
contenu mais plus au fait d'être exposé
comme ça sans avoir été avertis
être un peu pris de court justement cet
avertissement ben ils voient le jour
richard la réaction est même plutôt
rapide oui plutôt ces deux mois après
donc en mars donc deux mois après cette
scène de nu la direction de la chaîne va
prendre la décision va créer ce fameux
carré blanc qui convoie l'a d'ailleurs
il est en bas de l'écran à droite qui
deviendra plus tard un rectangle blanc
parce qu'on estime que le carré blanc
n'était pas assez visible donc la
décision est prise le 26 mars 1961 et
son nez son instigateur c'est lui c'est
philippe ragueneau il est sous directeur
des programmes de la première chaîne et
on les écoute en 1965 pour la première
fois il va s'expliquer sur cette
décision
les émissions qui se voient appliquer le
gard et blanc sont d'abord celles qui
relate une histoire susceptibles de
troubler profondément l'idée que se font
les jeunes du monde du bien et du mal
justifie aussi le carré blanc les
émissions qui comporte des séquences où
la morale traditionnelle et ouvertement
bafoués ou celles dont les scènes de
violence portent vraiment trop
violemment les sensibilités
là c'est assez intéressant ce qu'on a
entendu je sais pas si vous l'avez noté
donc effectivement des émissions qui
comporte des séquences où la morale
traditionnelle et ouvertement bafoués
donc en fait effectivement créer un
carré blanc dont pour avertir comme vous
l'avez dit quand il ya des scènes de nu
sans comprend que les scènes violentes
ça on comprend mais la morale est ce que
la télévision est garante de la morale
alors non c'est vrai qu'on a changé
d'époque aujourd'hui on est vraiment la
loi qui s'applique en termes de
régulation par la vente au de liberté de
communication et la liberté de création
donc on n'intervient pas sur la morale
mais en revanche on doit s'assurer et
donc c'est liberté absolue sauf en cas
effectivement d'appels à la haine
d'atteinte à la dignité de la personne
humaine on est plus sur ce type de
valeurs eux
que sur des valeurs morales qui
effectivement ne repose pas
juridiquement sur des choses très
tangible alors même au sein des chaînes
il ya aussi un débat sur ce carré blanc
comment est ce que ça fonctionne est ce
que c'est vous qui échanger avec les
différents médias justement pour pour
savoir où placer le gdir le carré dans
le curseur alors effectivement depuis on
a en a changé
en fait les chaînes se sont emparés
d'une signalétique que nous avons
élaboré éviter monde a travaillé avec
des psychologues
avec des professionnels de l'enfance
pour essayer effectivement de trouver
les bons mais bon le bon âge
donc on a une grille qui est partagé en
fait est connu par toutes les chaînes
donc chaque chaîne en son sein à un
petit comité de programme de vie donc
visionne les films avant qu'ils soient
diffusés et décide d'apposer la
signalétique en fonction effectivement
des images qui sont contenus dans chacun
des programmes
comment ça se passe à l'époque richard
justement dans cet échange dans ce débat
que l'on a au sein des châteaux autour
du carré blanc en tout cas c'est sûr
c'est que ça débat parce que c'est
intéressant c'est que même en haut lieu
on s'interroge sur sur de l'utilité du
carré blanc et je vous propose d'écouter
un extrait qui est assez incroyable
il s'appelle c'est jacques bernard dû
pousser le patron bleu et rtl donc à
l'époque ya deux semaines c'est le
patron des deux chaînes et il répond à
un téléspectateur on va beaucoup
d'émissions avec le carré blanc beaucoup
des messieurs alors pourquoi tous ces
carrés blancs parce que des fois j'ai
envoyé ya rien d'extraordinaire c'est
encore le carré blanc le degré de
moralité d'un d'une oeuvre c'est
évidemment aussi quelque chose de très
variable et de très subjectif il est
évident que moi aussi m'est arrivé de
voir certaines heures
je me suis demandé pourquoi on mettait
le carré blanc vous diriez quoi
aujourd'hui un patron de chaîne qui vous
diraient pourquoi est-ce qu'on mettrait
un carré blanc pourquoi est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui on protégerait le public
alors en fait je crois que le patron de
chaîne lui-même est soumis
à une pression de son public qui
souhaite que les justement les
programmes soient bien encadrés et que
le public soit bien aiguillé dans son
visionnage donc avant toute chose c'est
pour ça que cette signalétique que nous
avons mis en place elle est reprise et
même les chaînes sont appropriés et donc
ils décident eux-mêmes d'apposer le
déconseillé aux moins de 10 ans
déconseillé aux moins de 12 ans moins de
16 ou moins de 18 est en fait la
classification ne se fait pas sur des
valeurs de morale mais vraiment sûr y at
il de la violence de la violence
gratuite de la violence répétés y at il
de la pornographie
donc là on est sur du moins de 18 ans
donc on est vraiment sur des choses
assez tangible
est-ce que effectivement il ya des
images qui peuvent aussi heurté en
fonction des âges et c'est vraiment là
dessus que se basent note signalétique
et qui reprise ensuite par les patrons
des chaînes et les chargés de programmes
qui se disent mieux on classifie ran au
programme et mieux ils seront vus est
mieux perçu il pour éviter justement le
flot de courrier ou un email aujourd'hui
on vous dit qu'aujourd'hui c'est
tangible mais c'est vrai qu'à l'époque
ça laissait perplexe absolument donc on
voit là par exemple je propose des
images effectivement c'est un reportage
en 66 sur une femme qui se droguent donc
on voit une femme qui se pique donc
effectivement on comprend pourquoi
tout à fait il ya un rectangle basta
rectangle mais on a aussi mis un
rectangle blanc sur une pièce de feydeau
le dindon parce que ça va parler
d'infidélité ou alors on va mettre un
rectangle blanc sur la chanson qu'on
entend la de convois pardon c'est
juliette gréco qui chante déshabillez
moi parce que les paroles sont un peu
subjective c'est vrai que l'on peut se
poser quand même la question avec
l'amour se cherche un peu conscience oui
à l'époque oui et puis on était en fin
d'après midi c'est une autre époque
je crois que la morale était
était beaucoup plus présente aujourd'hui
donc on va sauter quelques étapes aux 79
ou met fin au carré blanc et pourquoi
réponse du directeur des programmes un
certain monsieur pères il est apparu que
souvent le carré blanc était une
incitation au contraire à regarder
l'émission et l'apport de sucre de ceux
à qui sa démission devait être interdite
alors finalement on a pensé que ça
n'était pas une mesure tellement
tellement efficace et tellement heureuse
voilà les autres chaînes vont suivre on
va supprimer le carré blanc il y aura un
grand espace et puis en 96 on va revenir
avec une nouvelle signalétique plus
moderne
ces trois cl un rond un triangle
rectangle rouge le triangle ou là on va
dire que c'est interdit aux enfants et
en 2002 encore en mai dernier un petit
peu la signalétique est là où on voit ce
que l'on connaît aujourd'hui c'est à
dire les chiffres qui sont dans les
rondes et là on ne l'interdît plus on
déconseille donc on a un peu joué sur
les mots on quitte apple domaine du
subjectif et je crois qu'en suisse
surtout ces signalisations c'est pas
juste pour dire aux parents regardaient
pas mais aussi des conditions de
diffusion ne peut pas diffuser ses
programmes n'importe quand les journaux
télévisés par exemple est-ce qu'il
devrait bénéficier ou d'une d'un message
de prévention justement contre le public
alors ce qui est intéressant concernant
les
journaux télévisés c'est qu'en fait nous
ce que nous disons c'est que ce ne sont
pas des programmes pour enfants
donc il n'ya pas de signalétique mais
charge au présentateur aux journalistes
qui les présente d'annoncer des images à
venir qui peuvent être violentes ou des
conseillers ou qui peuvent heurter la
sensibilité des plus jeunes
donc il n'ya pas de signalétique mais on
tient quand même à rappeler
qu'effectivement c'est pas un programme
pour enfants d'ailleurs on le voit bien
chaque soir où chaque mail à la mi
journée que les ânes les nouvelles qui
nous sont annoncés peuvent être
effectivement parfois troublante pour
pour les jeunes et concernant
effectivement la signalétique
d'aujourd'hui effectivement vous ne
pouvez pas diffuser on se base aussi sur
les horaires donc là c'est vrai que ce
film diffusé dans les années 50
à 20h30 impossible aujourd'hui on table
effectivement plutôt sur des deuxième
troisième partie de soirée pour diffuser
certains films et ça fonctionne plutôt
bien et aussi on se base en fait les
gens se couchent peut-être un peu plus
tôt les premières parties des marques
plus tard les dons par courrier les
prime time par dont les donc une
première partie de soirée démarre plus
tard donc après 21h souvent donc ça
permet aussi effectivement plus jeunes
d'aller se coucher et puis aux parents
de pouvoir regarder des programmes
qu'ils souhaitent
carole bien aimé baisse du conseil
supérieur de l'audiovisuel merci de vos
explications et de votre passage sur le
plateau de l'inattendu pour nous parler
du 60e anniversaire du carré blanc
voilà c'est fini l'inattendu pour cette
semaine prochain rendez vous mercredi
prochain sur le canal 27 après le
journal de 22 heures
bien entendu nous pouvons échanger toute
la semaine sur les réseaux sociaux que
ce soit ceux de l'ina ou ceux de france
info on est soit d'août